it's been a crazy week in america let's
find out what happened
after recently issuing an executive
order prohibiting mass mandates texas
governor greg abbott announced this week
that he had tested positive for the
coronavirus
even worse he announced it right into a
reporter's mouth
hey hey huh come here yeah come here huh
yeah
my mouth was open yeah it was following
following last weekend's collapse of the
afghan government president biden's
approval rating reportedly fell by seven
percent but that's not the worst fall
he's had
i
i love the
i love the like after the tripping the
nobody saw that
it goes on forever ever every time we
play it i go oh what a fun gift it's not
it's just one continuous
it just would have been perfect if he
like looked back a little bit to see if
anybody caught that and then everyone
went
[Laughter]
everybody saw that right no oh
i mean
twitter released a statement this week
announcing that it will allow the
taliban to operate on its platform as
long as they follow the company's rules
while facebook announced that they've
been run by the taliban this whole time
new zealand is under a nationwide
lockdown after one case of coronavirus
was discovered there ooh
new zealand's in trouble
tarek don't be mean new zealand is our
friend maybe we should call him just to
check up
terry pick up the extension it's all
right
new zealand residents may i ask who's
speaking um yeah hi this is amber ruffin
um i'm a friend of new zealand and i was
wondering if they could talk on the
phone right now
well i'm sorry amber ruffin but new
zealand is on punishment oh
well
well do you know how long they'll be on
punishment indefinitely but most likely
10 days ah come on mom don't make me
make it 14.
yes ma'am
um may i ask what did new zealand do
well if you must know they brought that
little delta variant in my house knowing
good and well i don't play i'll play
that under my roof
oh no how many cases one
one
well the u.s has 159
787 cases yeah and that was just today
okay well listen what miss usa does
under her roof is none of my business
but if i'm being honest they're not
raising y'all right making y'all pay for
health care in college and let y'all
play with guns
it ain't right um mrs new zealand's mom
miss um miss um
can we come live with you please
no no no no no no but listen i'll tell
you what if this pandemic ever ends
maybe you can come visit
yes ma'am
all right
bye bye now bye-bye
why your little friends calling my house
a southwest airlines flight attendant
reportedly asked a woman on a recent
flight to glue her child's mask to her
face because she wouldn't stop crying
added the flight attendant but as always
make sure to glue a mask onto your own
face before gluing one onto the face of
your child
according to a new study toddlers are
more likely to spread the coronavirus in
their homes than teenagers this study
was conducted by anyone who has ever
seen a toddler
[Laughter]
adorable please no please take that
picture down cut it out
freaking gross adorably gross gross i
hate it so bad they're so deep in there
and then yeah you're right and they want
to they want to you know you want them
to pick them up and no look
i'm sorry but
everyone who ever had a kid is bad
[Laughter]
[Applause]
cut to my mom texting me what did you
call me
monday was national rollercoaster day
and it threw me for a loop
yes
it did you do and finally a man in new
york recently set a guinness world
record by drinking two liters of a
sugar-free cola in under 19 seconds when
asked for comment the man said
and that was the monologue did you guys
like it
good
we wrote it just for you now if you oh
man
now if you follow the news you know that
u.s forces pulled out of afghanistan
this week and that shortly after they
did the taliban took control of the
country well republican congresswoman
lauren beaubert had something to say
about it on twitter
the taliban are the only people building
back better wow
bold take that brings us to a new
segment titled this probably goes
without saying
now this probably goes without saying
but you're welcome to join the taliban
i mean i don't think they're turning a
ton of people away right now so if
you're loving what you're seeing on the
news by all means you know
join the taliban lauren
of course i'm not sure when you'll be
able to catch the next flight to kabul
but feel free to snag one of those ticks
when they pop up on trivago
heads up due to covet rules you're
probably gonna have to wear a mask on
that flight and based on the fact that
you once threw a mask at a staffer who
asked you to wear one i'm gonna guess
that's not really your thing frankly
if you have a hard time following basic
rules you may not love life under the
taliban
or maybe you will heck maybe you'll
thrive maybe you'll become a famous
taliban politician so go ahead lauren go
join the taliban though i think this
probably goes without saying the taliban
aren't exactly nuts about women in power
but you know this everyone knows this in
fact one might say this probably goes
without saying
[Music]
recently
many white celebrities have confessed to
only washing their children sporadically
and uh
as a black person
this troubles me
you know i really want to talk to white
people about it but they're not the most
receptive
you know what they do respond to
black people sing in a little song oh
yeah
with mild choreography and matching
outfits what a good idea hit it
it's been a real rough couple of weeks
so much [ __ ] has gone down
california droughts and cosby's out it's
enough to make you ground
but just one thing
[Music]
guess what they're not brown
[Applause]
[Music]
you got so much money in your bank
account yeah you smell like a whole lot
of notes
man
but refuse to invest in soap
watch your feet we like that slide now
you all take pride in being gross maybe
you'll listen to the pope
[Music]
watch your kids
[Music]
now let's break it down
[Applause]
this detergent will do
make sure it's hot but not too hot at
night
[Music]
20 minutes
[Music]
[Music]
i have my own youtube channel now yay be
sure to subscribe for a lot of show
clips and a lot of digital exclusives
and a lot of this
[Music]
you